bienvenue dans une semaine dans le monde
l'actualité des 7 derniers jours vu par
nos éditorialistes avec à mes côtés ce
soir à CAC elle dessinateur de presse
président de Cartooning for Peace
bonsoir CAC Patricia Lemonnier grand
reporter bonsoir Patricia il y a de
l'imam directeur du mensuel Afrique
Magazine bonsoir ziades et puis Alain de
challeron grand reporter bonsoir merci à
tous les quatre d'être ici j'aimerais
d'abord qu'on revienne sur ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine en Ukraine des
bateaux chargés de céréales ont pu à
nouveau quitter le pays après la
volte-face de la Russie Moscou qui dit
avoir obtenu des garanties de la part de
Kiev et finalement revenu dans l'accord
sur les céréales signées sous l'égide de
l'ONU et de la Turquie et puis sur le
terrain alors que les troupes
ukrainiennes avancent dans la région de
Kerson au sud la Russie évacue des
civils et poursuit ces bombardements sur
les infrastructures énergétiques du pays
aujourd'hui près de des millions et demi
personne sont privées d'électricité en
Ukraine on va écouter à ce propos le
président
ukrainien veut le dire
ce soir environ 4 millions et demi de
consommateurs ont été déconnectés du
réseau en accord avec les programmes de
stabilisation d'urgence
notre défi au niveau national et de
surmonter cette terreur énergétique de
la Russie c'est l'un de nos principaux
tests désormais
ossements
Patricia lemonnière Hélène ce qu'il
parle de terreur énergétique que cherche
Moscou à briser la population
ukrainienne avant l'hiver
pas tant la population c'est à briser le
pays mais c'est dans sa logique si vous
les utilisent toutes les armes moi ça me
fait penser à la terreur qui avait voulu
instaurer Staline souvenez-vous pendant
la guerre la fin la famille un peuple 3
millions de morts ou plus je ne sais pas
donc là on en est effectivement pas là
mais c'est ça participe du même principe
le peuple n'a pas finalement pas
d'importance mais on veut juste montrer
que démontrer plutôt sa force et sa
capacité à nuire partout comme on veut
quand on veut
Anthony blinken ce soir il dit la Russie
tente de soumettre les Ukrainiens en les
faisant geler c'est ça la stratégie de
Moscou aujourd'hui compte tenu du fait
que il y a un certain nombre de revers
j'allais dire sur le terrain
conventionnel c'est dans sur le au sol
même si on voit que la bataille de
Carson qui est engagée déjà depuis
quelques temps on voit bien que ça bouge
pas donc il semblerait qui est quand
même une espèce de stabilisation du
front mais quand même sur le plan
militaire la Russie a pas davantage et
donc une des manières de montrer que
elle elle est militairement
incontournable c'est justement ces
bombardements répétitifs alors qu'ils se
font par missile très peu par avion donc
ce qui prouve que il maîtrise pas non
plus
maîtrise pas le ciel donc c'est des
missiles qui passent et dont un certain
nombre sont interceptés beaucoup de
drones iraniens ce qui posent un
problème entre l'Ukraine et l'Iran c'est
c'est c'est assez efficace ça a coupé
l'électricité ça coupe l'eau ça suppose
que il y a une très forte des
températures baissent les hivers
Ukrainiens sont quand même beaucoup plus
rudes que les nôtres ça va tester la
résilience globale de la population
ukrainienne mais c'est aussi un message
politique c'est-à-dire j'ai les moyens
excusez moi du terme de vous emmerder
jusqu'au bout c'est ne croyez pas qu'on
est dans une situation où
notre enfin semi faiblesse militaire ne
n'ouvre pas les portes d'une d'une
discussion politique pour le moment donc
on affaiblit l'Ukraine je pense pour
arriver à un point
où les Russes pourront dire il y a les
conditions d'un cesser le feu il y a les
conditions d'un début de sortie de crise
mais on n'y est pas encore
qui s'en est pris les céréales en
sortant de cet accord je l'évoquais
accord signé sous l'égide de l'ONU et de
la Turquie finalement Moscou est revenu
dans l'accord en disant avoir obtenu des
garanties de Kiev là aussi c'est une
manière de mettre la pression écoutez je
pense que oui à l'origine c'est ce qui
voulait et puis ça fait des ressources
aussi pour l'Ukraine c'est de l'argent
entre donc voilà c'était une manière de
de serrer un petit peu les cordons de la
bourse de Kiev mais ça n'a pas duré ça a
duré quoi 24 48 heures et puis ils ont
tout de suite compris que ça dépassait
largement le conflit de l'Ukraine que ça
touchait le monde entier et en
particulier les pays qui se sont
abstenus donc qui sont un peu neutres
dans le conflit finalement les pays
d'Afrique notamment
surtout les intérêts Turcs non
les intérêts Turcs aussi ils prennent
quelque chose au passage mais ils
prennent aussi des céréales même ils
s'approvisionnent
mais même les circuits ont changé c'est
vrai que le couloir mer Noire reste un
couloir important mais j'ai vu un
chiffre il y a une organisation qui se
met progressivement en place pour
évacuer des céréales par les autres par
la voie terrestre même si c'est plus
long
mystère dans ce revirement en 24 heures
moi je veux bien sur l'influence
d'Erdogan cette espèce de Superman de la
diplomatie mais quand même de prendre
une décision 24 heures et puis de le
revenir sur ses décisions moi je trouve
que tout ça est un peu troublant c'est
comme les aujourd'hui il faut évacuer
Kerson n'en couvre-feu et puis non pas
trop éloignés des zones dangereuses en
s'exprimer aussi tout à l'heure
donc il sem
[Musique]
je crois des troupes d'élite et les
évacuer vers la rive est du fleuve ou
est-ce qu'ils vont faire une bagarre de
dernière se battre comme un Stalingrad
vraiment je pourrais pas vous le dire je
pense qu'ils ont intérêt quand même à
libérer la ville et à partir de l'autre
côté du fleuve sinon ça va être imaginez
que les Ukrainiens gagnent que vous ayez
10000 12000 15000 soldats prisonniers
les mains sur la tête l'image terrible
quoi l'image terrible
est-ce que les Ukrainiens sachant que
s'il se battent et si les Russes
résistent la ville va être détruite
est-ce que les Ukrainiens veulent
l'offrir à leur peuple une ville
détruite c'est pas évident du tout ils
peuvent peut-être préférer mais là on
est complètement dans dans l'imagination
mais il y a parmi les options possibles
qu'ils veulent encercler la ville et
qu'elle tombe comme un fruit mûr sans
avoir à détruire donc tout le monde
parle de la bataille de Kerson la
bataille de Kerson n'aura peut-être pas
lieu enfin je crois qu'il est beaucoup
trop tôt ce que l'on peut constater
c'est une chose certaine c'est que les
évacuations comme vous le dites se
poursuivre 5000 personnes presque bon
qui sont ces gens on le sait pas non
plus de déportation mais c'est logique
dans la logique de qui elle s'appelait
que des gens qu'on déportent moi je peux
vous dire ça peut être aussi des prorus
qui veulent pas rester en temps de
guerre ou ça peut être des mamans et des
papas qui essayent de sauver leurs
enfants mais en se disant oui la
résistance s'est bien mais enfin sera
quand même un peu plus peut-être mieux
de l'autre côté du fleuve donc
on a une grande difficulté à avoir des
informations il y a une guerre de
propagande qui se livre qui est quand
même très importante et je crois qu'il
faut nous journaliste essayez de garder
un peu raison et d'analyser avec ce
qu'on a comme ça un peu sur le terrain
oui les Ukrainiens pour l'instant
attende les rues sont l'air de se
renforcer quels sont les gens qu'ils
amènent devant est-ce que c'est ces
fameux
mil faire absolument pas entraîné cette
fameuse dont on a parlé qui serait
devant ces fameuses unités d'élite comme
je pense que nos services de
renseignement savent nous encore on ne
sait pas trop et cette semaine il y a de
même le New York Times a affirmé que des
hauts responsables militaires russes
discuteraient de l'utilisation d'une
arme nucléaire tactique en Ukraine rien
d'iminant selon le journal Vladimir
Poutine n'aurait même pas pris part aux
conversations mais c'est tout de même
inquiétant d'autant plus quand on voit
ce qui se passe en ce moment à Carson le
problème c'est quelle est la stratégie
russe de l'utilisation des armes
tactiques faites on sait pas puisque
personne n'en a jamais utilisé donc
est-ce que mais je pense que le message
américain est plus plus subtil que ça
c'est on est capable de vous écouter on
est capable de savoir que vous avez une
réunion on est capable de savoir que
Poutine n'y était pas on est ça et je
pense que mais aussi côté le New York
Times dit aussi que du côté américain il
y a eu il y a des des réunions de
planning militaire sur la possibilité de
l'utilisation d'une arme tactique et
dans ces cas-là quelle serait la réponse
enfin tout le monde travaille sur le
scénario du pire mais c'est très très
étonnant parce qu'on parle du scénario
du pire et en même temps il y a une
guerre aussi qui est totalement nouvelle
avec les drones on est au 21e siècle et
voilà que les drones deviennent l'arme
enfin l'arme par excellence l'attaque du
port de sébastopold quand même c'est
impressionnant moi j'ai vu les images
sur Twitter de ces petits bateaux qui se
sont faufilés dans la passe et qui sont
allés percuter des navires des navires
comme c'est assez impressionnant ces
espèces de drones j'allais dire Ikea
fabriqués par les Iraniens qui arrivent
quand même à se faufiler et à taper
quelque part donc
dans le monde moderne avec des armées
surpuissantes on
avait vu l'utilisation de ces armes
aussi sur d'autres théâtres en Arménie
en Azerbaïdjan etc
et on voit comment
ces armées suréquipées avec des
équipements lourds en fait sont
fragilisés par des choses plus légères
techniques qu'on peut contrôler à
distance où il y a pas mort d'homme si
le drone il part en Brie c'est assez
impressionnant on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
si les
Ukrainiens ont encore en avait beaucoup
parlé au début du conflit de ces fameux
drones Turcs est-ce qu'ils en ont encore
on en entend plus du tout parler ils
utilisent toujours des drones les
Ukrainiens ils ont fabriquent même aussi
et je voudrais juste revenir sur cette
fameuse écoute des des Russes parlant de
la fameuse arme salle qu'on peut appeler
mais il est logique que des militaires
parlent de ça je veux dire c'est pas
comme être le monde militaire donc c'est
plus comme message de la part des
États-Unis de sortir les militaires
russes c'est logique qui parle de toutes
les armes qu'ils peuvent utiliser si le
chef leur demande donc forcément ils en
parlent entre eux et donc ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les Américains
utilisent effectivement cette
information mais qui est logique à la
limite pour en faire une information
d'une menace et donc nous on se prépare
à cette menace mais le propre du
militaire c'est de se préparer et de
d'envisager toutes les possibilités tout
l'usage de toutes les armes que va lui
demander le chef
je suis tout à fait d'accord c'est le
travail d'un état-major tout simplement
les états majeurs prévoient tous les
scénarios possibles donc y compris
aussi que les Américains étudient au
sein de leur état-major la façon dont on
pourrait répondre à ça
que ça donne quoi la garant en Ukraine
cette semaine en décembre je découvre
grâce à vous qu'il y a un point commun
entre les militaires et les dessinateurs
je m'y attendais pas c'est qu'on imagine
aussi tous les scénarios possibles donc
j'ai dû pour il y avait beaucoup d'idées
dans tous les sens j'ai choisi deux
grands sujets qui dominaient les dessins
cette semaine sur le sujet de l'Ukraine
deux dessins sur la peur du nucléaire
quand même qu'on voit revenir beaucoup
chez les de nombreux dessinateurs on va
commencer par un dessin de Vladimir
casanovski grand dessinateur ukrainien
actuellement exilé qui montre ce Poutine
avec un visage totalement ambiancé
Halloween je sais pas s'il était marqué
par l'actualité en train d'essayer de
faire du feu avec celui-ci un peu ce
geste préhistorique et évidemment sur un
bouton rouge dont on aura bien reconnu
le sens j'aime beaucoup ce dessin
graphiquement kaznanski est complètement
fou et puis ce deuxième sur le même
thème ce deuxième dessin de amaurym des
signes grande dessinateur brésiliens qui
imagine donc c'est bombardements qui se
rapprochent de plus en plus de la peur
du nucléaire j'ai bien aimé cette
métaphore très étrange presque poétique
de ces petites bombes sous forme de
doigts qui pour l'instant tombe à côté
du bouton je trouve ça assez à la fois à
la fois amusant et terrifiant bien joué
à Maurine et l'autre thème qui revenait
beaucoup c'était la fin la guerre de la
fin et donc je vous propose deux dessins
pour illustrer ça d'ailleurs là nous une
nouvelle métaphore cette fois-ci desmad
age dessinateur jordanien pour Al Arabie
aljadid il a reconstitué une sorte de
drone avec vous le voyez couteau
fourchette hier je trouve ce dessin très
créatif c'est une belle idée évidemment
l'assiette est vide vous l'aurez compris
et puis enfin Nicolas vado dessinateur
belge de référence dessin fait pour
l'écho qui lui note que ça y est enfin
des Russes et les Ukrainiens se sont un
nouveau mis d'accord et donc on peut
reprendre l'import et l'export
merci beaucoup avec CAC on va partir
maintenant au Brésil son arrivée au
pouvoir ne devrait pas changer la
position justement du Brésil vis-à-vis
de Moscou le Brésil indulgent avec la
Russie depuis le début de cette guerre
en Ukraine on parle bien sûr de Lula le
leader de la gauche brésilienne qui a
remporté avec
50,9 % des voix le second tour de la
présidentielle dimanche dernier passage
à air bolsonaro le président sortant
d'extrême droite aujourd'hui la
transition elle semble enfin engagée la
contestation des résultats perdent
l'ampleur il y a nettement moins de
barrage routiers qu'en début de semaine
le président sortant à même reçu le
vice-président élu aujourd'hui au palais
présidentiel GR bolsonaro qui après
plusieurs jours de mutisme a affirmé
mardi qu'il respecterait la Constitution
l'écoute
j'ai toujours été traité
d'anti-démocrate mais contrairement à
ses accusations j'ai toujours agi dans
le respect de la Constitution
de la République et comme citoyen je
respecterai toujours tout ce qui est
dans notre Constitution
on craignait des violences et puis
finalement
on peut dire que la situation a été
plutôt calme les partisans de
gerbolsonaro certains ont bloqué les
routes cette semaine mais rien rien de
plus il y a eu des incidents
particuliers il y a eu des agressions
pour beaucoup d'observateurs pas
d'inconnus sur le plan militaire il y
avait pas de risque d'une intervention
militaire mais donc ça ça s'est confirmé
moi je pense que bolsonaro et peut-être
un petit peu plus subtile qu'il en donne
l'impression et qu'il sait que d'abord
il a perdu d'un tout petit peu il a des
forces au Congrès qui sont importantes
il a des forces dans la rue qu'il peut
mobiliser au doigt et à l'oeil il peut
faire du Trump c'est à dire il peut
s'installer dans cette posture de
victime même s'il le dit pas
Trump l'a dit carrément m'a volé
l'élection bon là on en est pas là mais
il cette capacité trumpienne
il peut avoir un certain nombre de
casseroles jurides judiciaire et
juridique qui peuvent le le le paralysé
mais moi je pense qu'il fait de la
politique qu'il sait qu'il a 49, quelque
chose du Brésil il sait qu'il a les
grandes villes on parlait avant
l'émission de la carte des votes Sao
Paulo Rio Manaus etc toutes ces villes
ont voté toute la force de l'évangélisme
donc
il il va peser il peut très bien dans
quatre ans et de nouveau là il va pas
disparaître de la scène et c'est la
leçon de ce scrutin c'est vraiment ça
c'est que on est dans un pays divisé 55
ans presque avec un président dont on
espère beaucoup mais qui n'aura pas un
congrès facile à gérer pour faire passer
des textes on espère qu'il va sauver la
planète la forêt et tout le reste avec
la démocratie etc bon il y a beaucoup de
fantasmes autour de cette situation qui
est en fait un président élu
ras les râle elle est pas crête
va falloir se battre pour pouvoir
exister politiquement vraiment
Patricia lemonnière cette courte
victoire de Lula c'est quand même un
avertissement pour la gauche brésilienne
elle gagne mais de justesse et
puis c'était surtout un front
antibolsonaro qui a remporté cette
élection effectivement elle gagne de
justesse et a vraiment un phénomène qui
s'est passé qui s'encre dans le pays
c'est le bolsonarisme qu'on aime qu'on
n'aime pas mais ça y est ça n'existait
pas maintenant ça existe et ça peut ça
peut se développer et puis surtout Lula
arrive dans des conditions qui sont
radicalement différentes de celles qui
est arrivé en 2003 en 2003 la Chine est
en plein boom économique 10% de
croissance voire plus les matières
premières s'envolaient là c'est la
récession mondiale c'est c'est la
panique à bord etc donc ce n'est pas du
tout propice aux échanges et le Brésil
compte beaucoup sur les échanges c'est
pas propice au prêtre etc le pays était
aussi isolé alors il va sortir de son
isolement on le voit bien déjà la
Norvège est sensible au fait que ça soit
Lula qui arrive pensant qu'il va d'un
seul coup arrêter toute la déforestation
ce que je ne crois pas mais elle s'est
déjà prête à lui à lui faire à lui
redonner en quelque sorte les enveloppes
budgétaires qui avaient été promise dans
le cadre de l'arrêt d'une déforestation
donc je crois que il soulève
effectivement comme la dysiane beaucoup
d'espoir il va avoir une tâche
excessivement difficile des adversaires
déterminés donc il va te falloir trouver
au centre du monde avec qui gouvernait
et la partie comme vous l'avez dit ça va
être excessivement difficile pour lui et
nous on se fait peut-être un peu trop
d'illusions au fond d'un peu trop
d'espoir peut-être sur ses capacités ça
va être ça va être compliqué pour Lula
comme disait Patricia Lemonia il trouve
le pays dans pas du tout dans le même
état non c'est sûr mais ne boudons pas
notre plaisir on est dans une telle
merde de partout que bon là il y a une
bonne nouvelle tout d'un coup
vous savez c'est pas inhabituel que des
élections se jouent à 51 49 c'est le
rôle c'est le la logique de la
démocratie il a eu quand même 2 millions
d'euros que justement ils contestent les
résultats si c'était trop serrés de plus
quand même pour pour Luna bon c'est vrai
sur relativement serré mais enfin c'est
quand même une victoire je dirais à peu
près incontestable j'aimerais bien
savoir ce qui s'est passé pendant les 48
heures
au bolzonaro n'a rien dit est-ce qu'il a
eu des interlocuteurs au téléphone
est-ce qu'il a eu Washington au
téléphone est-ce qu'on l'a convaincu de
finalement ne rien faire est-ce que les
militaires qu'il a pu aussi avoir au
téléphone lui ont dit écoutez ne comptez
pas sur nous on ne fera rien
oui peut-être c'est aussi son
vice-président qui est un général à tout
de suite reconnu sa défaite il a dit oui
bah ok on a perdu
ce qui est l'élément le plus rassurant
de toute cette histoire c'est que les
institutions ont tenu c'est le tribunal
le tribunal spécial électoral
l'institution militaire n'a pas bougé il
y a quand même
il y a quand même le fait que là aussi
on avait beaucoup craint un espèce de
débordement massif mais bon quand même
les images qu'on a vu de ces millions de
gens dans les rues pour dire reste avec
nous bolsonaro ça va pas partir
là il y a pas eu de débordements cette
semaine mais pour l'instant Lula n'est
pas encore officiellement président il
sera en poste à partir du mois de
janvier il reste un peu plus d'un mois
quand même et ce qui pourrait y avoir
encore
écoutez ceux qui descendent dans la rue
parle d'un article de la Constitution je
crois que c'est l'article 142 qui
prévoit que les militaires peuvent
intervenir si la loi et l'ordre sont
bafoués alors c'est vrai qu'en
ce moment avec des médecines partout
éventuellement un peu de violence bon
les militaires pour élire oui ben on va
appliquer cet article 16 la Brésilienne
mais je crois pas
et puis la pression internationale est
quand même forte c'est à dire le premier
message est américain 12 minutes après
c'est préparé on envoie un signal en
disant que le signal a été fait même
avant je crois que les proches comme
vous dites sont c'est très important que
les proches de bolsonaro est tout de
suite tout de suite reconnu très
important parce que on ne s'y attendait
pas c'est ce qui nous a le plus surpris
que les institutions tiennent à la
limite mais que les proches qui l'ont
soutenu porter à bout de bras comme le
disait Alain tout de suite reconnaissent
la défaite chapeau ça va changer la
place du Brésil sur la
[Musique]
la défaite de bolsonaro c'est une
défaite de 2 millions de voix sur 124
millions avec un congrès avec un congrès
qui n'est pas un congrès favorable au
nouveau président et donc on peut très
bien être dans une situation de semis
paralysie avec un bolsonaro qui pourra
de son balcon à ranguer les foules
l'évangéliste Dieu etc les évangélistes
qui sont les plus j'ai envie de dire
les plus malléables en quelque sorte
elle est plus déterminée sur lequel
bolsonaro pourrait jouer mais ce qui va
être très intéressant à voir aussi c'est
l'attitude du de l'agroalimentaire de
tout le secteur agroalimentaire et des
entreprises agroalimentaires est-ce
qu'elles vont accepter de collaborer de
travailler avec Lula ça c'est on ne sait
pas il s'est allié avec celle qui est de
la femme qui est arrivé numéro 3 et qui
est très proche de ce lobbying et on va
voir il voulait juste ajouter un mot à
ce que disait Ziad il a tout de même
très bien réussi Lola pendant les deux
le mandat qu'il a eu le pays s'est
développé
l'économie était très positive il a
réussi à éliminer une bonne partie de la
pauvreté du pays voilà donc il y a un
bilan quand même il y a un bilan chez
Lula il a quand même été aussi élu en
fonction de son passé justement on va
regarder le contexte
oui le contexte international a changé
mais on va regarder ce que ça donne en
dessin kak ce retour de Lula alors ce
qui était très frappant dans les très
nombreux dessins qu'on a qu'on a reçu de
la perte de dessinateur c'est d'essayer
des préoccupations complètement
différentes des visions complètement
différentes entre les Brésiliens et les
non brésiliens donc pour les
nombresiliens je vous résume c'est une
victoire de l'environnement et ne
parlait quasiment que de ça tous les
dessins donc j'en ai choisi un pour
illustrer ça de Pierre Balouet
dessinateur français président de
l'association France cartoon avec donc
ces deux natifs qui disent c'est Lola
ils ont l'air assez réjouis et on voit
évidemment l'état dans lequel
j'aime beaucoup ces tronc d'art
complètement disproportionné assez assez
très beau dessin alors que pour les
Brésiliens et donc maintenant on va
passer au dessinateur brésilien et
essentiellement le grand sujet c'est
l'état dans lequel se trouve le pays
après le les quatre ans de Jaïr bonne
Solaro donc avec d'abord un dessin de
qui voilà celui-ci de Machado qui nous
montre j'aime beaucoup cette métaphore
très surprenante de ce train que
bolsonaro aura fait rouler mais à côté
des rails pendant 4 ans et donc
évidemment on voit la fois l'état du
train et du paysage ils ont tous les
deux le nez rouge oui je ne sais pas ce
que ça signifie
donc peut-être que ça ne sous-entend
rien je ne sais pas ou alors celui-ci
encore de Thiago look à où vous voyez
Lula en train d'essayer de réanimer le
Brésil qui s'est noyé et ses petites
bulles qui sortent de la bouche qui
forment évidemment vous arrivez à le
lire le nom de bolsonaro donc pour les
dessinateurs brésiliens c'est surtout
l'état du pays qui les marque et donc la
tâche de Lula on va laisser le dernier
mot à gargalo dessinateur portugais
n'ont pas brésilien mais l'isophone
qui résume très très bien ce que j'ai vu
dans beaucoup d'autres dessins aussi
c'est ce pays fracturé en deux un peu
comme les États-Unis après la défaite de
Trump d'ailleurs ce pays fracturé en
deux que le soudeur Lula va devoir
essayer de recoller merci beaucoup Kia
justement va parler après des États-Unis
mais d'abord on va partir en Israël ou
là aussi il y a un revenant un peu plus
d'un an après avoir quitté le pouvoir et
ben benyanim Netanyahou et de retour
sont partis le liquide a remporté les
élections législatives de mardi le bloc
de droite obtient 64 sièges sur 120 à la
knees 7 une majorité relativement
confortable mais avec le soutien des
ultras orthodoxes et de l'extrême droite
regardez
à 73 ans Benyamin Netanyahou fait son
retour un huitième mandat avec cette
fois-ci une majorité confortable pour
gouverner 64 sièges au total pour sa
coalition des droites à gauche le
Premier ministre actuel lapide à acter
sa défaite j'ai parlé ce soir avec le
président de l'opposition Benyamine
Netanyahou et je les félicité pour sa
victoire aux élections l'État d'Israël
est au-dessus de toute considération
politique et je souhaite le meilleur à
Netanyahou pour le bien du peuple
d'Israël et pour l'État d'Israël après
avoir été chassé du pouvoir en 2021
Benyamin Netanyahu prend la tête de la
coalition la plus à droite que le pays
n'est jamais connu
il dispose désormais de 42 jours pour
former un gouvernement mais tout ne sera
pas aussi simple pour l'ancien Premier
ministre il va devoir négocier des
postes ministériels clés avec ces allées
d'extrême droite les ultrasorteodoxes et
surtout les suprématistes juifs qui
deviennent la troisième force politique
du pays l'un de leurs leader Itamar
Bengué condamné plusieurs fois pour
rappel à la N homophobe veut annexer
toute la Suisse Jordanie
il faut s'attendre à des changements de
politique notamment en ce qui concerne
les fondements de la démocratie
israélienne les freins les contrepoids
et en ce qui concerne l'indépendance du
pouvoir judiciaire car Netanyahou est
toujours poursuivi pour corruption et
trafic d’influence selon plusieurs
sources en Israël il pourrait même être
tenté de se faire voter une immunité
donc cerné par les affaires de
corruption et ça n'a pas rebuté les
électeurs israéliens Patricia lemonnière
c'est le contexte sécuritaire qui
explique son retour le contexte
économique comment expliquer cette
victoire non je crois que c'est un
glissement du pays qui se renforce dans
le côté le plus nationaliste qui est qui
est au sein du sionisme et donc cette
tendance avec c'est il y a juste il y a
trois deux trois ans il y avait il y
avait maintenu dans la loi juive que les
rappeler dans la loi juif que l'État
d'Israël était un État juif donc c'est
une c'est une tendance lourde qui est
née il y a de ça j'ai envie de dire ces
dernières années et qui et qui se
renforce et Bibi netanyahous sa liant
avec les suprémacistes comme il était
dit danse dans ce sujet ou avec les plus
religieux du parti et bien en fait ce
n'est que le de l'évolution d'une
société qui est j'en finirai avant de
laisser la parole aux autres c'est il y
a un journaliste d'arête qui disait une
chose très juste les électeurs de cette
frange là ce sont des électeurs qui
viennent essentiellement du Moyen-Orient
du Proche-Orient ou du Maghreb et donc
ce sont des gens d'origine qui ne sont
pas en des pays qui connaissaient la
démocratie au sens où nous lançons dans
le sens où les Ashkénazes les à
l'origine qui ont peuplé Israël la
pratiquait donc c'est journaliste que je
ne fais que citer d'arêtes et bien
disait en fait ce n'est pas un vol
religieux c'est un vote tribal en
quelque sorte voilà je je donne ces
propos c'était très sévère mais c'est
une une réflexion qui peut alimenter le
débat en tout cas on assiste à une
droiteisation aujourd'hui de la société
israélienne le parti
s'appelle sionisme religieux qui est le
parti le plus à droite qui est
suprématiste
en 2019 il faisait
1,88%. et là plus ce type pour cent ça
montre l'évolution du pays alors tout à
l'heure je vous disais pour bolsonaro
que c'était plutôt la bonne nouvelle du
jour mais là ça se fait pas la bonne
nouvelle franchement
bon on est où on le connaît c'est pas il
a jamais rien fait pour que le processus
de paix soit relancé jamais rien fait
pour améliorer la situation des
Palestiniens il a utilisé pas mal de
violences aussi notamment sur Gaza mais
bon on le connaît en revanche les
suprématistes religieux qui étaient un
peu exclus de la vie publique
pas un peu même il y a eu des moments où
c'était carrément interdits
et la sécurité publique en plus alors on
peut se demander où va aller Israël avec
des gens qui tiennent des ministères
aussi importants alors que leur c'est
l'expulsion plus récente des
Palestiniens de t-shirts vraiment je
trouve ça inquiétant alors c'est vrai
qu'on est habitué maintenant à ce
conflit du Moyen-Orient et puis on
entend de parler parce que ça n'avance
pas mais là c'est quand même à mon avis
très grave j'ai dit même en même temps
la gauche israélienne elle a pas su
répondre aux attentes de la population
qui ont montré que si les travailistes
et les mérettes c'était allié ils
auraient eu les voix pour arriver à
60-60 au Parlement il y a eu un effet
hier lapide aussi qui est assez
intéressante c'est-à-dire que il a
siphonné la gauche en fait parce qu'il a
eu lui un progrès personnel sont partis
à gagner 7 ou 8 siège qui est énorme
Israël donc il est à 21 sièges il est le
chef de l'opposition mais en siphonnant
ce qui était plutôt sur sa gauche mais
aussi en s'ouvrant à lui personnellement
un boulevard mais un chemin politique
est très clair il est le chef de
l'opposition et il incarne l'autre
Israël
séculier si on peut dire est à droite et
qui avait entamé malgré tout des
relations avec les Arabes d'Israël qui
était déjà un peu meilleures donc il
représente une alternative après il y a
ce bloc de droite avec quand même ce
monsieur qui est cible Benjamin non non
je parle de Benjamin janiou merci
poursuivi par la justice par la police
par tout le monde c'est rare on sait pas
quoi en faire on sait pas comment s'en
débarrasser bon il est là mais pour les
Alliés historiques des États-Unis et
pour les nouveaux alliés du pack
d'Abraham c'est une situation absolument
intenable c'est-à-dire les Américains
vont faire des contorsions mais ils sont
quand même extrêmement gênés aux
entournures mais tous les nouveaux
alliés arabes
aujourd'hui
avec des ministres qui qui prônent la
violence anti rap mais pas que la
violence anti-rable et c'est le point
sur lequel je voulais venir
la société israélienne est quand même
des gens qui sont contre le droit des
femmes
homophobe antiéminité anti LGBT
contre les Arabes israéliens mais les
Arabes aussi Palestiniens de des
territoires donc on se demande comment
cette société va pouvoir absorber une
telle violence contre une partie
d'elle-même parce qu'il y a pas que les
Arabes qui sont il y aura pas que les
Arabes qui seront menacés c'est les les
Juifs séculiers qui représentent quand
même une partie de la population vont
être menacés donc on va voir comment
tout ça va fonctionner bon après il y a
master biby dont le seul objectif est de
survivre
que les juge meurent avant lui peut-être
et peut-être que lui trouvera cette
espèce de de
tambouille politique pour éviter que ça
dérape mais il a toujours su s'allier à
la gauche enfin au centre à cette dans
cette mouvance là là ça va être là ça va
être difficile
c'est le non participation des Arabes
israéliens à cette élection
et et le seul chemin pour ce que
j'allais dire les séculiers maintenant
proche de yayapide c'est de créer des
alliances avec des Arabes israéliens
pour pouvoir porter des votes qui leur
donneront la possibilité d'avoir une
majorité parce qu'il n'y aura plus de
majorité au centre gauche sans alliance
avec les Arabes israéliens qui ne
veulent pas voter parce qu'ils se
reconnaissent pas dans le système et
nous en Europe ça va nous poser des
problèmes parce qu'avec hier Lapid il y
avait eu un vrai rapprochement Israël
était venu au concert avait participé
déjà à des réunions européennes il y
avait un vrai un vrai travail de
rapprochement qui se faisait on a
l'histoire du gaz on a des on est on a
des projets qui Israël et si on se
retrouve si les pays européens se
retrouvent avec des pays qui qui prônent
l'exclusion de de des Arabes de la terre
enfin un régime de type raciste ça va
être complètement à l'encontre des
valeurs prenées par l'Europe et là je ne
sais pas comment l'Europe va se
débrouiller mais cette droitisation en
Israël on y assiste aussi dans d'autres
pays je pense à l'Italie par exemple
Hongrie dans d'autres démocraties même
aux Etats-Unis on va en parler dans un
instant c'est un phénomène mondial cette
droiteisation on pourrait dire que même
en Russie enfin l'évolution de Poutine
lui-même va vers la droite et oui c'est
vrai que c'est inquiétant c'est
inquiétant comme on le disait aussi pour
le Brésil avec la montée en puissance
des évangéliques donc des religieux et
là en Israël on voit aussi des religieux
qui qui gagnent des points il y a le
retour du religieux et le retour des
nationalistes ça fait assez explosif et
et paradoxalement il y a des sociétés
qui se dé religieuses par exemple en
France les statistiques montrent que on
est moins religieux dans le monde arabe
toutes les enquêtes qui sont menées
montrent que les jeunes on voit des
femmes voilées on ne voit que ça à la
télé mais la réalité c'est qu'il y a une
des religion dans les pratiques
quotidiennes sont plus religieux ce qui
reste religieux
affirme avec une force qui n'affirmait
pas avant leur appartenance à la
religion que ça soit chrétienne que ça
soit juive ou que ça soit musulman on va
regarder quelques ce que ça donne en
dessin ce retour de Bibi aux affaires
c'est exactement ça pour les
dessinateurs j'ai d'abord voulu regarder
ce que disait les voisins d'Israël je me
suis regardons d'abord j'ai dessin par
exemple qui vient du Liban de Hassan
Bebel que j'ai pris parce que il est
très simple il est vraiment très simple
mais la caricature est très réussie il
est même beau espèce de bleu cyan
majestueux et donc bon bah il se passe
de commentaires le grand retour de Bibi
évidemment qui occupe la place de
l'étoile de David donc c'est elle qui
joue aussi sur la religion pour pour
accéder là où il est donc très beau
dessin qui vient du Liban un autre qui
vient de Jordanie le même et madaja que
tout à l'heure à l'Arabie algébrilité
bon vous aurez reconnu la référence
cinéphile j'imagine c'est Shining de
Kubrick normalement ça devrait être Jack
Nicholson dans cette porte fracassée
je vous rappelle la scène est quand même
très très flippante donc là c'est à
nouveau caricature je trouve assez
magistral c'est bibi qui fait son grand
retour et puis alors ensuite j'ai
regardé évidemment parce que faisait les
dessinateurs israéliens nous avons ici
Kichka dessinateur d'Israël pas
forcément un grand soutien de benamine
House qui nous montre qu'il a passé son
temps donc à cartonner la démocratie les
procès la police la gauche etc et ça lui
a plutôt réussi il a l'air assez content
de lui pour ce dessin de Tichka et enfin
dernier dessin alors ce qui me frappait
c'est que personne dans toute cette
grande zone géographique ne parlait de
la Palestine j'ai dû revenir en Europe
pour voir ce qu'on pensait tir de
regarde dessinateur des Pays-Bas qui lui
montrent que évidemment tout ça c'est
fait aux dépens des Palestiniens sur le
dos desquels on marche pour pouvoir se
mettre en valeur des seins je trouve
assez fort de tirs royale merci beaucoup
CAC on va partir pour finir aux
États-Unis plus fidèle alliés d'Israël
ou l'ombre de Donald Trump la plane sur
les élections de mi-mandat nous sommes à
J - 4 et selon les derniers sondages et
bien les démocrates sont à la traîne les
républicains semblent certains de
l'emporter au moins à la Chambre des
Représentants alors que la campagne elle
a été marquée par des intimidations et
des violences le président Joe Biden a
mis en garde contre les risques de chaos
et l'estime que la démocratie est en
danger on l'écoute
[Applaudissements]
hier soir j'ai parlé de démocratie à la
télévision nationale j'ai dit que la
démocratie se trouvait dans le bulletin
de vote une grande partie de la presse a
posé la question légitime pourquoi
est-ce que je parle de démocratie ce
n'est pas une blague alors pourquoi
est-ce un problème et bien la raison
pour laquelle j'en ai parlé et que 70%
des Américains d'après un sondage
pensent que la démocratie est en danger
en ce moment
il y a trop de violences politiques trop
d'intimidation il y a plus de 300
négationnistes électoraux chez les
républicains cette année pour les
gouvernements d'État fédéraux et locaux
c'est vraiment sérieux
plus de 300 candidats
du 8 novembre donc de mardi 1 qui ne
reconnaissent pas le résultat de la
présidentielle 70% des électeurs
républicains qui continuent à contester
la légitimité de Joe Biden toute cette
remise en question de ces résultats de
la présidentielle c'est c'est inquiétant
il y a un vrai danger aujourd'hui pour
pour la démocratie aux États-Unis oui il
y a un pré danger je pense que byden a
raison c'est pas aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
c'est depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
Trump est plus encore après la dernière
élections qui ont été donc contestés par
Trump qui continue à contesté par Trump
puis il y a eu l'assaut sur le Congrès
le 6 janvier donc c'est c'est un gros
problème que les États-Unis ont
effectivement ce pays qui sacralisait sa
constitution ne la respecte plus et donc
il va falloir trouver une solution alors
est-ce que vous disiez que les
démocrates n'étaient pas favoris ce qui
est vrai mais
si vous m'aviez posé la question il y a
dix jours je vous aurais dit oui c'est
plié il y a rien à faire en revanche
depuis 10 jours il y a eu quand même
cette attentat contre Nancy Pelosi enfin
c'est son mari il est con oui mais
c'était elle qui était visée et ça je
pense que ça va quand même susciter un
peu de réflexion il suffit de quelques
pourcents c'est pas et donc ça a été
appuyé par Biden qui appuie là où ça
fait mal et donc ça peut éventuellement
faire évoluer quelques résultats à tel
point que le Sénat
peut-être sera toujours
incertains il y en a un qui est assez
amusant c'est la Géorgie où il y a un
candidat républicain qui est très très
anti avortement mais qui a payé
l'avortement de sa maîtresse il y a
quelques années donc notez que c'est sa
maîtresse que c'est quand même
cette violence dans cette campagne à
l'ancien l'a évoqué cette agression
contre le Marine d'antipelosi il y a eu
aussi eu des hommes armés à proximité de
bureau de vote en Arizona parce qu'on a
déjà commencé à voter avec le vote
anticipé tout ça c'est inquiétant c'est
le résultat de l'air Trump oui c'est le
résultat de la trompe c'est le résultat
d'une évolution de la société et puis je
pense aussi qu'il y ait une erreur
tactique de l'équipe Biden c'est à dire
que Biden a fait ses sa campagne
tranquille j'ai envie de dire sur
l'avortement en disant et bien vous
voyez ce droit à l'avortement qui a été
retoqué annulé quelque sorte par par les
républicains on peut le dire pour ça
comme ça moi je vais vous le remettre si
nous gagnons les élections c'est pas ce
qui intéresse aujourd'hui les Américains
les Américains comme tous les Français
comme tout le monde ne sont préoccupés
que par leur niveau de vie par l'essence
qui a monté etc et les républicains ont
fait toutes leurs campagnes en disant
tous les malheurs qui vous arrivent le
niveau de la vie qui augmente vous voyez
que vous ne pouvez plus faire rouler la
récession qui nous criminalité dans les
grandes villes la criminalité mais c'est
surtout l'économie c'est surtout
l'économie qui préoccupait les
Américains et bien ça c'est la faute de
Biden et les démocrates leur ont laissé
jouer sur sur cette route qui est un
vrai boulevard pour eux il y a de ils
ont mal fait campagne les démocrates
déjà le sortant a toujours des
difficultés
le chef est pas très flambant
les chiffres sont pas mauvais quand tu
parles d'économie il crée beaucoup
d'emplois et tout mais c'est des emplois
qui sont pas très bien payés et donc il
y a d'une part une anxiété des classes
populaires américaines de déclassement
mais il y a aussi excusez-moi un fond
idéologique chez une partie de ces
républicains religieux anti-état
anti-gouvernement anti-toux et qui
s'exprime et qui utilisent des moyens
sur lequel les démocraties n'ont pas de
prise les réseaux sociaux le complotisme
le type qui débarque chez vous avec un
marteau si tout va bien que tu es riche
et que tu as pas de problème pour le
boucler les fins de mois ça prend moins
quand même ça donne quoi en dessin alors
très rapidement
3 dessins complètement différents
d'abord de piettes dessinateurs français
qui lui est sensible à cette partie
isolationniste chez les républicains qui
sujet dont on n'a pas parlé qui peut
être souvent tendrait qu'il faudrait
réduire en cas de victoire des
républicains réduire le soutien à
l'Ukraine ça a marqué le dessinateur
Piet qui nous propose donc la nouvelle
arme secrète des Russes qui n'est pas
une bombe mais qui est l'agent orange
évidemment vous aurez reconnu Donald
Trump symbole de cette partie
isolationniste de chez les républicains
alors évidemment il faut se moquer de
tout le monde donc Willis from Tunis
destinatrice tunisienne elle propose
plutôt de se moquer de Biden un dessin
pour cinéma mensuel
USA l'élection de mandat mesdames
votaient pour moi et je rétablirai le
droit à l'IVG j'ai comme l'impression
qui nous attrape par la chatte
évidemment ça ne rappelle cette phrase
abominable qui a été prononcée par non
pas Biden mais Donald Trump pour s'en
souvient avant son élection la première
fois et puis ce dernier dessin de moi
puisque si je viens vous voir
aujourd'hui il faut quand même que je
vous montre un petit peu mon travail
pour l'opinion et donc là ce sont ce
nombreux c'est nombreux électeurs
répulsés dans vos élus républicains qui
à nouveau ont laissé sous-entendre que
peut-être ils ne reconnaîtrait pas le
résultat donc j'accepterai le résultat
sauf si je perds pareil répondent
Vladimir Poutine
merci Alain Chalon merci Patricia
lemonnière c'était une semaine dans le
monde restait avec nous l'information
continue